I don't even know what happened I think
my mind was still stuck in the past so I
literally see mediums on the boxer brief
and I think I would like that
okay I got what I needed that's what I
need right there
I go home and I'm like yes because I've
been freeballing the whole day I'm like
cool I got underwear and I opened the
pair of shoes I'm like what the [__] is
this
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys wow
this one's not gonna be that awesome
this one's gonna be wow yeah this is
going to be this is gonna be boring yeah
go ahead Bart Bart told us that he
bought triple XL underwear because his
day his week's been rough it's been
rough those last couple days what is
your underwear size sure typically it's
usually medium wow that is a hard day
you have to go triple so I have more
than really baggy you wanna see my
[__] bag underwear on
that oh you actually wore it I have to
oh yeah so like I have to roll up the
waistband too like a girl
this is mostly boxing you're wearing
shorts yeah who's rolling him up like a
girl with gym shorts those are literally
bigger than your barbell Brigade shorts
yeah look at that do you have like a
surgery or something no no did you have
a surgery or something Ryan's like I
know why you're wearing those was it on
sale no I just had so much [__] going on
the other uh yesterday and I knew I was
supposed to come here that you forgot
your dick size no so you know like
sometimes like you're like I should
probably write everything down and
you're like nah I'll remember it y'all
remember it's it's fine and then so as I
was coming by the time I thought it's
like medial not [__] it I'll Remember by
the time I was halfway halfway on the 15
to La I was like things that I should
have been doing I was like oh [__] like
[__] my laptop charger oh [__] I didn't
bring that that's fine I could do with
that and then I go oh [__] off the film
three workout videos this week oh [__]
around my gym bag you know just like one
thing afternoon so relatable why what
did you do just
did you just run out of the house I just
had too many things and then so by the
time I got to uh I got to
um Geo's mom's house I opened my luggage
and I'm like the [__] I literally packed
everything except for underwear I mean
this is [__] [__] and your laptop
charger engine back and the other [__]
yeah and I'm like what the [__] man it's
like I feel like all like
discombobulated because I'm usually like
got my [__] in order I'm like oh [__]
I'll go to Target I'll go buy buy some I
go to Target and then I don't even know
what happened I think my mind was still
stuck in the past so I literally see
mediums on the boxer brief and I think I
would like that but I don't remember
going like that so I grabbed it I'm like
okay I got what I needed that's what I
need right there
go home and I'm like yes because I've
been free balling the whole day I'm like
cool I got underwear and I opened the
paper and I'm like what the [__] is
[Laughter]
any [__] things I had a moment like
that yesterday
that was the whole story yeah I had
moments like that when you're just so
[__] busy that you actually waste
more time [__] like haste his waist
style oh yeah like I remember so I
literally ran back and forth five times
because
um from my office to the bathroom
because I forgot the bathroom key each
time
or something else yeah five times
because it's impressive because like I
would go oh [__] I gotta pee and then oh
wait I gotta write that email so I
forget to pee there's too many things on
my mind oh okay I finished the email I'm
gonna go to the bathroom I go to the
bathroom I'm like [__] the bathroom key
so you go back into the office and
you're like oh I forgot this other thing
and then you finish that and you're like
oh wait I gotta go pee so then you go
and you're like [__] the [__]
bathroom
and you go back and then you grab the
bathroom key and you go to the bathroom
you go I need my phone though cause now
I gotta take a [__] so you run back and
then and you put down the key to get you
put down the phone go back and you're
like [__] it's just covered in Piss
well yesterday literally like I had a
whole build up right I had a whole
[__] build up of [__] in my mind and
then
um I [__] texted Geo because she knew
like I was kind of like discombobulated
and kind of like
um I literally texted I was like my
life's kind of whack right now
so that's what you said to us this
morning my life is so [__] whack
right now I went to Target could have
sword grabbed medium boxer briefs guess
what size they are double X you guys
have a haircut it's like a domino effect
of like why is everything [__] up and
I'm just [__] going down this like
it's like a state of mind thing like you
enter this Zone this is like retirement
home stand-up comedy right now hahaha
and then I checked and it's double XL
and it's cute baby yeah and the room's
like I've been there my God that
happened to me you never had a rough
week like they were random [__] I'm not
saying I haven't I'm saying I wouldn't
tell 50 000 people uh twenty one
thousand five twenty one yeah yeah
I think we were like likes when we were
younger but we just so [__] like go
with the flow that it didn't matter we
just it didn't it didn't even occur that
it was a problem or we got our [__]
together and now things are unraveling
again I got one
so yesterday I'm leaving Las Vegas we're
not supposed to have Christmas lights up
for too long and our neighborhood or
else you could get fined so I had to go
out into my backyard and unplug my
Christmas lights already but it was
raining it's January it was raining so
then by the time I get back inside I'm
tracking mud on the ground like I need a
real ding dong
so then how can you Steve I take off my
shoes right take off my shoes and I
start walking them inside but guess what
they're dripping model over the ground
anyway
foreign
have we all turned into middle class
dads well you guys are so Suburban no
we're just highlighting the fact that we
have off days but really we also have on
days you know when you're just like in
Zen mode and you just feel like you're
killing it yeah what have you been
killing you've been killing it these
days no I'm just saying you know when
you have I have I don't remember when
the last time I had one no uh but but
there are those modes right where you
just [__] annihilate everything you
just feel like you can tackle the world
these are just the other days like when
the kids Dojo shut down wow that's
crushing it yeah that was like a killer
that was exactly like double XL [__]
this is what I was doing with my
business decisions
I like the idea of you does that ever
happen where you really focus on a thing
and you do this but to be fair at Target
all those [__] things are all jumbled
up oh is that why
in section but it was in the wrong
section dude it's all [__] up but you
also shouldn't use a peripheral vision
to grab what's important you know what I
mean you should probably look the other
day I bought [__] tank tops at Ross
and [__] and then every single one
smelled used and [__] warned you wait
you smelled them before you grabbed I
put it on and I was like it smells like
you know how it has that brand new you
know it has a brand new smell maybe it
was original but it was like sweaty it
was returning and brand new at the same
[__] time you didn't you don't wash
it first I was in a rush I was going to
a wedding I get it Brock's got those
deals bro
I was in a rush so I had to go to the
Ross to get a tank top it was probably a
freaking a sheisty return maybe no
sometimes you get those because I
smelled it and I was like
[__] [__]
College dance team that had to wear this
but that's also how I found my barbacoa
because I was looking for chicken
tenders blessings blessings and then the
peripheral vision was like oh what's
that and I grabbed her and I got the
Barbacoa at Target this is gonna be a
really good video this is already a
really barn burner a barn burner this is
gonna get a [__] streamy did you take
your first bite like this
what I had the chicken tikka masalis
just I like how we haven't seen each
other in like a month and then the story
that we talk about is this was because
I'm afraid to be like what'd you guys do
for the holidays and this video gets
uploaded in three months yeah the
topical ones are tough it's like hey
what's your New Year's resolution what
did you do for the holidays then yeah
what'd you do for Fourth of July oh yeah
let's get ready for a Valentine's what
are you thinking you're about to do I
saw you revealed that you got married
yeah finally the reveal okay so that's a
big deal that's funnier beautiful what's
funny is when I heart's broken
everywhere you guys are a beautiful
couple man yeah you guys are great I
didn't know it was gonna be that legit
you had the little you had the little
chain bro no it looked really good the
photography and everything was great I
didn't know you had a full I thought it
was a private private like I thought it
was like so private that like it was
like it had the quality of a public
wedding yeah yeah also I noticed a
little dig at JK in one of those photos
yeah what was oh yeah what was the date
well because well because you were you
were reading your vows to each other but
then you told us you would never tell us
the vows I was like
well the funny thing is what happened
was uh me and Nina were back and forth
about you know it's like hey we're gonna
tell people what not I was like uh yeah
you know what what time is right right
and then one day I come home and then
I'm like uh babe we just shot like uh an
off the record with JK and uh we kind of
talked about everything did we yeah no
we did yeah we did it's already uploaded
so that's what I texted YouTube I texted
both of you guys you [__] you're
on the text but you were getting [__]
extra extra large underwear all right
Bart you know we're the ones who drink
right we're not supposed to remember I
was probably holding the phone and this
earbud's probably here now this ear
you're probably getting ready to turn
off the video while I was talking about
the love of my life he's like so I got
married Bart's already getting up
[Laughter]
he's like I'm getting married Bart's
looking at the clock
the title is literally okay though I did
that's right I texted both of you
actually I texted him a few times over
the weekend anyways that's not the point
um oh yeah to see Shin Lim yes yes oh
you finally saw him no I did it I did it
you guys are gonna go see Shin Liam
I didn't get it two years in a row he
hasn't seen Shin limp yeah you see what
you did all right so I text him don't
leave me like that so I text both of
these guys and I'm like hey when is that
video coming out because I think that if
like me and Nina don't come to an
understanding of when we tell people on
our own terms they could cause a divorce
she's gonna get mad at me right they had
the wedding reveal becomes a divorce
trigger so then Joe's like oh you could
you could text or email the producer
they got the schedule blah blah blah
blah right and then so I'm like okay
cool but I'm I'm in [__] I'm just
doing some other [__] right I finally
get down to it I get into an email and I
write an email to producer I'm like hey
uh when does this video scheduled to go
out because I need a blah blah blah and
then right when I sent that email and
needles give me a hard time she's like
you said an email I was like yeah
something about cool and then I was like
I should check YouTube and I checked
YouTube and that video was uploaded one
hour ago see we're good man why don't
you email immediately when I told you
why you waiting oh because I was busy
doing stuff that was the part where I
said I'm I was busy doing stuff I
literally added that disclaimer anyways
and then I was busy too what were you
doing yeah I was texting you about shin
Lim all right um and then I finally had
to I had to email her back and be like
oh never mind I just saw it my bad and
it was already up well at least most of
your friends and family don't watch JK
so that's really good that's true 100
none of my friends would subscribed to
JK not at all everybody thinks it's [__]
yeah yeah same same same thing they come
to the show but they don't watch
I think it's terrible I love having I
love having Nikki on the show and she's
like I don't even watch the show
dude my dad was like Hey so I started
watching uh JK and I was like I was like
I was like Dad stop [__] watch it's
not for you yeah I was like turn your
[__] eyes off yeah they'll spoil your
brain goes you know I thought uh Bart
was gonna be taller
that's what he's saying
he goes like yeah he stood up and I was
like he's a big guy I didn't know he was
going to be like not that tall that's
what he's focused on not the not the
fact that he told stories about my dad's
like a couple inches smaller than me
like he's like what five six that's why
he thinks your parts big yeah yeah yeah
does he know that you talk did I [__] my
dad yeah yeah I said that not enough uh
but he was like he's like yeah you guys
are just talking [__] me right yeah you
guys are just talking [__] the whole
time I was like Dad stop he pulls up
that video about you wanted to fight
your dad he's like
I didn't know Bart was just kind of
that's him like going into trauma mode
right now I was talking [__] hey what do
you think Bart's body fat percentage is
it's pretty impressive do you know what
his macros are
what's his diet like so how was that
talk like afterwards it got revealed
were you guys like she wasn't mad was
she like whatever of course not of
course she would ever be mad at it but I
also did have to rationalize like nobody
we care about watches JK that's so true
but then what made your transition to
let's tell everyone we care about now uh
well uh because that they follow her
Instagram yeah my original anniversary
with her was on New Year's just one of
those cheeky little moments like nine
years ago when you like asked somebody
to be your girlfriend on like New Year's
after like a little ball drop kiss and
stuff like that you know what I mean
yeah or unoriginal but point is our
original anniversary was on January 1st
yeah and she was like she's like oh
should we post it I should post it I'm
like I'll just kind of like low-key over
Instagram and general for a bit now it's
just a season I'm guessing but I just
just my natural thing it's all the
little people stuff in your algorithm
maybe I took a long break it's okay he's
seen it all he's like yeah I just took a
long break uh so I was just kind of like
oh whatever whatever feels good and then
you know came to like the holidays
people were like posting about [__]
random stuff on Christmas yada yada and
she's like should we post about I'm like
ah it's Christmas I don't know you know
and then finally she's like what do you
want to post about it and I knew that
this video was gonna the OTR video was
gonna drop before the end of the year so
I was like we should do it at the end of
the year for sure and I was like oh why
don't we just throw it on our original
anniversary because we're never gonna
celebrate that again like why would you
celebrate that you guys don't celebrate
that anymore the original January first
one we celebrate our original more than
we celebrate our way that's how we are
too ours is January 2nd mine's the same
day [__]
January 2nd oh well congratulations oh
congratulations
congratulations congratulations oh well
congratulations to that then
congratulations wait why do you guys
celebrate the original more than your
wedding because our original is like
yours we actually got together on
Christmas on Christmas so you would
rather celebrate Christmas versus like
your anniversary versus Christmas you
don't want two different celebrations no
no we we have a special moment during
Christmas now because we got together
during Christmas but then the wedding
day is like so like um like logistical
you know like what's what's a good
weekend like who who's free or whatever
so it's like a random you're competing
with Christmas and Jesus's birthday you
know that Bart when Bart says he has a
special moment he's like all right I got
15 minutes at this moment
it's like why don't you celebrate the
other ones too logistical all right so
what are we doing what are we doing here
because the wedding day is just it's
like what works the photographer was
open Okay cool so like we're celebrating
the photographers availability day you
know what I mean I mean if you
downgraded to that yeah I understand
the photographer's availability day dude
my wife
choose the wedding you choose that day
it wasn't a day that magically or
organically happened that's true yeah
that's why we picked the same day that
we got together that sounds like that is
a dunk actually we did the next day
because it was like two thousand dollars
cheaper let's see yeah but that's also
why I'm moving mine because our original
anniversary is on January 1st but the
thing is for the last eight nine years
I've always had a hard time with my bank
account because there's Christmas on
25th then there's our anniversary then
her birthday is January 28th and then
Valentine's two oh that's a drainer
gauntlet I've been getting [__] yeah
yeah Cox for like like years so now
being able to move our actual
anniversary to like the end of September
I'm like all right I got some space like
better plan certain things now I can go
a little bit more ham on her birthday
don't say anything now I can go a little
bit more ham on that how much you're
spending each time dude first of all you
know how many times I had to be like all
right this gift is actually for these
three things combined okay that's fine
like I'm sorry I didn't get you
something Christmas because I have
something for you for this three pack of
10 tank tops
how long have you been together
uh this January 1st would have been
quotable officially eight years but like
nearly nine years of dating because you
know how many times we've been We're not
gonna get each other anything right yeah
cool all right cool cool did you guys do
this last year we didn't get each other
Christmas or anything this is what we
did oh this is our first year me and my
lady were like no gifts oh wow we're not
gonna do this so but did it is it
because it used to be a routine it
started it started as a thing you did
and then now you're just like all right
let's not do it it was just like I don't
feel like I need anything like I'd be
like what do you want for Christmas yeah
cause it ends up into that kind of
conversation yeah and I'm like I don't
need anything and then you start to have
so many other things that are more
important we're planning on getting
presents for all the kids because we're
like actual adults in the family now
yeah so now you have like 30 presents
you need to get and so now it feels like
getting each other presents kind of
becomes like a more less Hannah got me a
sick ass present because she was
watching the video where it was like
which what do you want for Christmas and
I was like I don't know I don't see she
actually watches
that's very sweet
and then and then I was like I don't
know I was like maybe a paddle board and
then like she's like and I totally
forgot that I said that [__] so then I
was like and I'm I don't buy things for
myself until like I'm I deserve it
because I have to make goals right or
else I'll never get [__] done so I'm
like I'm gonna wait till the stores open
and then I can remove my whole family
out then I'm gonna buy a paddle board
and I was like putting it in my head and
I was at Costco the other day and I was
like yo look it's an inflatable paddle
board and she was like you don't want
that thing it's that thing's gonna break
and I'm like you you never ever tell me
not to buy [__] yeah yeah this is
suspicious so I was just like I was like
she's lying to you that's the first time
you didn't support like something that
was fun yeah and I was like come on
Hannah but I didn't think about this
later I was like we just had to buy some
[__] we just had to buy some [__] right
so he bought some [__] and then she like
it wasn't even like Christmas it was
like three days before Christmas she's
all like can I give you your gift
[__] Christmas she's like this
motherfucker's gonna buy it tomorrow
and then she has my nephew she's like I
need help though I need help carrying it
I'm all like what did you get that you
need help carrying and it didn't even
register my mind and then later on she's
like all right all right it's Christmas
now we have to do this but I hid it in
the neighbor's like side of the wall and
I'm like what now I'm [__] confused
it's actually the neighbors though but
so I'm waiting and then her my nephew
walk out they both have to hold this
thing it's the size of a [__] kayak
it's so big that it won't fit on my car
and I'm like what the [__] is this but
it was like a big bright pink uh paddle
board yeah that's dope sounds like she
stole a paddle board from the neighbor
kid
basically yeah bright pink that's bright
[__] pink big ass [__] it's like two
of these tables put together it's a 12
foot 12 foot it's like a size of a
[__] sailboat hey but you're gonna be
stable on those Waters yeah she's my boy
because he was like you know what I was
thinking is we can all get down there
like four of us on there with a picnic
hang out and she goes and you can fish
and I'm like we should have just got a
boat
did you try it out already no we I can't
even fit it on my car so I need to get
my buddy who has a truck and we got to
put it on his truck and then we gotta
find him so I need to buy a plane
[Music]
those those
like we don't give give I just give her
when I know that she wants something and
then she talked about it and I'm like oh
I saw it and I'm like oh I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get that thing that's cool
yeah me and Nikki's love language is uh
time together or whatever quality time
not um gifts yeah so we we just like for
this year we just wanted to go to Mexico
so we put everything towards that looked
dope it was tight were you were in
Mexico I was just in Mexico oh yeah
that's right you sent this you look like
an oil Baron too with your hat and
everything I know I look sick right
I look like a Kingpin
no we went to Puerto Vallarta yeah yeah
you're not nailed it and uh yeah it was
so sick because our neighbors like have
a house there so we're like [__]
we're gonna Puerto romearta with you
guys yeah how long was the flight was it
direct from Vegas even though it was
like
kind of fly to like [__] Colorado and
then go to Puerto Vallarta yeah it was a
pain in the ass but it was but it was
cool once we got there yeah
um it's like 80 degrees over there right
now oh dream yeah oh the mosquitoes how
was that uh do you remember I asked you
about the mosquitoes you did ask me
about the mosquitoes
because I heard that the West Coast of
Mexico is like the West Coast here where
there's not that many but the East Side
you get [__] up dude dude I don't
think mosquitoes like me very much I get
[__] up over here dude I get destroyed
by mosquitoes I think honestly Nikki
gets [__] wrecked and I'll be sitting
right next to her and I don't get any
mosquito bites at all you got that area
in blood right I think it's because I
drink so many monsters that they're like
yo this blood's bad
do you not eat a lot of sugar no I don't
I think that's that plays a role oh yeah
yeah that some people have said if you
have like sweeter blood they come after
you
you breathe hard because they're
attracted to CO2 and if you have high
body heat
yeah Nikki has sweet sweat even because
I don't I never that's kind of hot dude
it is hot you said that yeah yeah that's
love
you never get bit I never get bit really
they don't like your blood yeah you
don't need sugar huh I got bitter blood
you don't need sugar not really they
like mariki and people who Breathe hard
that's me bro I get [__] lit up
eating alive everywhere I go and I don't
I don't sweat either so that's probably
another thing that's [__] I'm jealous
of you yeah I'm jealous so much I'm
jealous you wanna I want to sweat I
don't want to sweat Grass Is Always
Greener okay I need to get rid of these
toxins man
the ones that you don't drink or inhale
yeah what are you talking about what
toxins secondhand smoke the ones that
come out when you put your feet in that
water at that freaking bogus freaking uh
you ever seen that those little fish eat
your eat your feet and then the water
turns black wait what I know that fish
but not the [__] it's like a scam
thing yeah yeah I don't know what that
is so that's 21 minutes
it's a boring story there you go
foreign